hello everyone and welcome back to the
2019 isle of man chess tournament it's
Luke McShane vs. Bhaskaran odd even odd
even always an exciting player whenever
he plays pieces are just flying
everywhere and the look machine they
often describe him as the world's
strongest amateur as not only see a
chess grandmaster but also he works as a
trader in London's find that fine
financial sector so a very exciting game
I do hope you enjoy it without further
ado let's check it out yeah so a machine
with the white pieces opens with efore
with c5 Knight to f3 with d6 and now
Bishop to b5 check the canal attack same
as in yesterday's game that Carlson
played Bishop to d7 with Bishop captures
and here Carlsen capture with the Queen
but Audubon captures with the night with
Knight captures and e7 he goes for a
different line with castles by McShane
and now Knight G to f6 quinta e -
preparing to push e5 in some lines and
now e 6 with d4 by white C capture Sun
before night chapters on d4 and now a 6
c5 not allowing black to push d5 and now
rook to c8 in just continuing
development the black will soon develop
the dark square Bishop Castle and white
goes for b3 adds more protection to the
to the beasts report and will be finicky
at winning the dark square Bishop with
g6 by Audubon he will also feel yet of
his dark square Bishop with Bishop to b2
Bishop to g7 and Knight to c3 McShane
continuous development and finally
Audubon castles with castles and now
there is a game that reached disposition
in that game rook F to D 1 was played
but here McShane chooses rook a to D 1
and it is as of more 13 that we have a
completely new game so what happens here
black continues development we have
Queen to c7 and King to h1 a nice
prophylactic move and if there are any
beginners watching this you might be
wondering why should you waste a move
playing King to h1 it's just it's not
easy to know when a king - h1 is a
useful move and when it's just a waste
of time but I remember reading McHale
tall once said that
when Black has a dark square bishop and
his queen has access to this diagonal
Queen to b6 followed from b6 the Queen
has access to this diagonal then it's
basically always useful to play King to
h1 but there are exceptions so the more
you play chested the more you will know
whether to play or not to play King to
h1 here King the h1 by McShane and now
rook F to d8 continuing development and
now f4 now you are ready to play f4 as
the king is no longer on this dangerous
diagonal Queen to b8 leaving the the B
file the C file open for the rook and
also preparing to push b5 at some point
if the knight moves Knight back to f3 by
McShane and now comes Knights to h5
attacking the f4 pawn and asking machine
what do you do here also the night if
this Knight moves now black can also
trade the bishops here and remove some
of White's attackers but what do you
play here so the Queen is a bit
misplaced here on b8 and Weiss it
definitely has some attacking potential
here but how do you go about the
position McShane warned a brilliant
attacking game yesterday and now he has
he has a potential in the position to
start the attacking again and he does he
pushes f5 here f5 starts the attack
immediately but there was also the
possibility of playing Knight to g5
point being Knight to g5 prepares f5 and
black doesn't have a good way to
response to this you have to you have to
allow it for example if b5 then F 5 is
just stronger because it already comes
with a double attack against the e6 pawn
and if DF I'll somehow opens up then the
rook and the night will be very
dangerous along the F file on the other
hand after Knight to g5 you don't you
don't have a good way of pushing the
night away you can't really push f6 the
e6 pawn falls if you play h6 then this
is a well this is the dream how to
attack here King characters and now push
f5 black doesn't have a good way of
responding to this whatever he plays
let's say e 5 you're gonna capture here
with a double check King captures and
now you will for example queen g4 check
win back your your your sacrifice piece
so nice the g5 seems like a tiny
improvement here but the McCain
confident in his attacking abilities due
to yesterday's the result pushes f5 and
okay rook to e8 adding another defender
to the TD e pawn F captures F characters
and now a beautiful positional move you
know in the style of old masters 'if
I've a nice pawn sacrifice that clears
the e4 square for whites night we have
nice factors on e5 Knight captures an e5
bushel capture so black wins upon but
now Knights the e4 opening up this this
bishops diagonal which says do you want
to trade bishops but there isn't really
a much better move whatever happens that
white can always trade on e5 and mess up
black's pawn structure so here a black
decided to trade with Bishop captures
Queen captures and now look at all of
White's pieces are targeting well the f6
square so you have to do something about
this there is a you could go rook to f8
to grab more control of the e6 of the f6
square but a demon goes d5 instead his
idea is that okay if you play pawn
captures pawn captures then it's just a
very good position for me for me since
your knight is attacked here you have to
move it also you cannot capture and
allow this sacrifice because after rook
to d7 you don't have anything the g7
square is nicely guarded by black's
knight on h5 so here are the band played
d5 and you know we always say in the
Sicilian if you can play d5 play d5 it
will it will be good for you but if you
can't play it then it didn't it just
doesn't work and this is one of those
cases where this is just a too early
push of the of the d5 pawn better with
rook to f8 just trying to regain control
of the f6 square oh but you know feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the best move for white in this position
so if you've seen the tongue thumbnail
then you know which which is the best
move in this position and if you haven't
and if you found it nevertheless then
congratulations on finding such a nice
move and if you just want to enjoy a
show it is of course g4 just threatening
if the if the knight moves for example
Knight to g7 or whatever then look Luke
is ready to use the fork Knight to f6
will of course win the game pick up the
the rock win material and that's it
and if you don't do it you don't really
have much options after G for this is
what McShane played audubon was forced
to capture we have capture sunny for now
comes captures on h5 and again
rook to f8 seems like the the more
resilient a way to go but Audubon
chooses C 5 instead he decides to close
the Queen's diagonal but it it doesn't
help him all that much because now
McShane goes H captures and g6 with H
captures and g6 and Queen to g2 now and
now with this if I move what what
Audubon
basically did is he prevented his Queen
from re-entering the game you could play
Queen to c7 but it's it's just too slow
there's no way there's no good way to
prevent Queen captures here so Audubon
tried rook the c6 he defends the pond
for the moment but rook d7 now and now
the Queen can no longer enter the game
so it was either you allow Queen
captures and g6 or your queen is not
entering the game and the other rook can
also come to f7 now which will be
extremely dangerous we looked at these
six Audubon offers the trade-off a pair
of rooks but now what would you play
here we already mentioned that the
arrowroot can come to f7 what's better
is it is this better or is this better
so how do you of course you don't want
to trade here you like you're attacking
potential but to which rule goes to f7
in the game McShane played rook d2 f7
but this rook to f7 should end the game
on the spot but it requires some
calculation there is no move you cannot
capture here if you care if you try and
trade off now then you're just getting
made it check and mate so there's a
there's no point in even trying this so
the only and you cannot allow rook rook
g7 the check otherwise Queen to h3 and
Queen to f2 will will easily checkmate
the black king so you're only good
option here is rook d1 check allow look
captures and then capture the f7 pawn
but now the black king is just in in the
mating net a queen F to check King e6
otherwise if you go to the King side
rook d7 is coming so here at Queen's the
b6 check you go back King g7 now Queen
to g6 check and
there is nothing for blacks to do here
you cannot enter the game with the Queen
if you try Queen to c7 than just Queen
Queen g7 check will pick up the Queen
the the King cannot go anywhere along
the d-file Queen see it you can try to
bring the Queen into the game this way
but the just Queen d6 check and now
again King f7 rook f1 check King g7 and
now Queen f6 check and that's just it
you're quickly getting and getting made
it either you go to g8 or or h7 doesn't
really matter if you g8 they look to g1
check and then it's made along the H
file or or you can give up the Queen but
that's just pointless you're gonna go
here and this is just me too
so although this requires some
calculation it's not all that it's not
all that difficult to calculate it but
they were both very low on time so
McShane decided to go for the for the
most well I wouldn't say easier but the
most straightforward way with rook d2 F
7 now the idea is very simple and you
know by just looking at the position
that this is winning so even though the
other variation is a bit more forcing
you know that this is winning because
after this rook comes to f6
there is no preventing Queen captures
and g6 this pawn will fall so black
tried to bring the Queen enter game
Queen to c8 and now comes just rook 7 to
f6 as planned
so now you can trade once but then when
the other rook comes to d2 d2 the 6th
ranked Queen captures on g6 is coming so
rook captures on f6 with rook captures
on f6 and the now rook the e7 there's no
preventing the Queen captures in g6
or Roe characters and g6 for that matter
we have rook captures on g6 with check
here King the h8 and now again how do
you continue the attack you can go Queen
h3 the queen is covering that Square and
even if you could then the rook will be
able to block this would rope to h7 so
McShane finds the easiest route to the
to the win
Queen to g5 it comes with an attack on
the roof so you have to react Queen the
f8 defending and now either rook to h6
or Queen to h5 is good just Queen to h5
check forcing rope to h7 and
then you recapture character queen
characters on e5 so rookie seven Queen
captures on e5 with check and the rook
to g7 and now for the last time feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea in this position so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations it's not all that
difficult but and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is it is
very educational if you are just
beginning your chest journey if you're a
beginner you have to know that the the
King and pawn end game is winning here
so it's something you should always be
able to do in your own games just look
at the position try to imagine that all
the pieces heavy pieces and queens are
off the board just look at the king and
pawns and if the endgame is winning you
just trade pieces so this is one such
idea you you will just trade everything
queen characters queen characters fruit
character skin captures and now King to
g2 and it was in this position that
bhaskaran audubon resigned the game as
the Kingdom point is completely winning
if there's some of you that are perhaps
interested it's completely winning due
to White's H pawn it's it's just too
strong for example if King f6 you're
just gonna bring King F to King e5
you're gonna bring King III and our
black has to waste a few moves you just
start marching your h1 up the board a5
you're just gonna play h5 and now the
black ink has to go and pick up the h5
point otherwise you're just gonna Queen
it King a5 you're gonna play h6 king g6
now you pick up the pawn and after black
captures the point you're gonna go over
to the Queen side and pick up those
pawns as well King g6 Queen c6 now the
King will try and come closer but now
it's three points again zero points of
course this is completely winning so
both both of them of course know this
and after King to g2
addabani resign the game and with this
victory I believe Luke machine is now in
joint lead with Fabiano Caruana Vanko
and and the part homework zulu there are
all on three and a half points so really
exciting stuff and we're gonna see what
happens in round five so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Justin dink a leak at cater party
and that one for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the isle of
man chess tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and everything
that happens in the chess world so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day